[Music]
I'm becoming non-functional practically
and doesn't bother me as much about
people's into them we had to create or
giant people think of them drunk baby
I'm Timothy I'm 62 years old I'm an
interpreter and specializing medical
devices I have to voice or scroll I have
a wonderful life and I'm listening to
better my conditions or the doors before
when he got the diagnosis we were
stunned
he's always been an athlete and not just
you know the weekend warrior type but
we're talking like biking across Greece
and you know boxing and doing all these
other things and I think my initial
reaction was panic
[Music]
every time I have the challenge I'm
tempted to read only so I heard that's
an opportunity to show who I am really
he was determined to act as if this were
minor inconvenience and that I think was
the thing that really got me to stop
panicking and to thank you okay I got to
approach this in a different way I mean
I don't know what I would have done if
he had just you got that diagnosis and
said oh my god
you know I'm done
[Music]
[Music]
we see traces on three electrodes top
one is the inferior one the middle one
is in the middle and this one is the
posterior one so right now it's pretty
quiet kind of like an oscilloscope this
is the one second sweep and when we see
neurons you'll see little vertical
deflection those are single action to
counsel as an architect
okay so I'm going to stop here for just
a second and check a feed of the
electrodes now that I'm confidence
they're out of the cannula
my first concern was what do I say to my
kids because that was a concern and you
know kids are very good they pick up on
things you don't have to say a whole lot
they kind of see where things are going
and so I did talk to them about it but
they also took their cues from their dad
who once he was diagnosed with
Parkinson's within the first couple of
years said okay so let me make a plan
here that I think will help me in the
long run so when surfing was something
he took up after he was diagnosed with
Parkinson's
[Music]
part of my protective nature is I want
to make it all better
like right away and I've learned to
trust him
initially when he started windsurfing
which you know it was and on the open
water okay we're talking ocean it scared
me to death and I I was all over him
doing them that one time the Coast Guard
came by
I took a longer open I tied myself to
the shore and then I went to a buffet I
could do a couple sitting on the open
ocean
okay so that scared me a little bit
right so I had and everything about
southern Peter Coleman okay I mean I was
able to go back and forth by the ferry
boat to cross the little penguin we
wouldn't have the problem
[Music]
[Music]
okay ah get some blood your hands yeah
the lightbulb
so you how you get a screwdriver good
dad let's got the Oakland A's I'm no
sucker all right do it again hopefully
with your hand oh it's good the
lightbulb my time to feel - you say
better or worse news came to Britain
take a better look loser today look for
food try again
so I'm going to fold your hand the light
bulb and then usual sensation from this
tingling any like that okay no you're
not okay a little pull pull okay go like
a statistic for his color dungeon
okay feel better now I said and yeah
this is a really like quick and dirty
cat so it would be much more much finer
would you don't get it just in the
office okay so I'm just going to take
you know it's a security in place and
it's closed up so go to relax go drive
take a nap whatever that's I think
there's a lot of hope in terms of what's
out there so there's so much research
going on tech down so I'm hopeful that
the D brain stem lawyer will give us buy
us some time to the next
[Music]
[Music]